long time friend and a colleague from
ESPN and now with the NFL Network the
award-winning journalist and NFL Network
chief correspondent that's quite a title
Andrew Kramer good to see you
I have a huge question for you okay yes
well that pillow help with snoring yeah
I may need to buy a vat of them for my
husband but drop the promo code rich
Andrew and for you especially for you
get bike specialist family here you're
finally here me we've been talking about
that new way to talk to rob this was
quite some time I know you know I Amy
Trask made it here before you how did
that with with the cube yes she's gonna
be here on Friday
right she'll be all right yeah so what
what is going on with you right now like
what are you working on NFL Network
world or real sports was all right now
what are you actually right now I'm in
Los Angeles because on Thursday we have
the 13th annual Los Angeles sports and
entertainment commission yes you've been
involved about like some time okay yes
and lucky 13 you know it I teach at
Boston University and one of the things
I always tell my students is be
pleasantly persistent so after 12 years
of asking Commissioner Roger Goodell is
going to be one of our speakers tomorrow
longer our very close friend al Michael
ow
and and REMS all access so we'll have
Sean McVeigh and cut and em off and Wade
Phillips whose book I saw you have I
just finished it the son of Bombay fire
for you guys who came here so working on
that and then I also have a real sports
piece that they'd use next week on the
show on Tuesday want me to be a well and
then and then the NFL Network in the
fall and obviously with what we're doing
right now and you know al it's funny
Al's been here his books over there and
we had him last year in February the day
after the anniversary of the Miracle on
Ice and I hooked him up with Ken Dryden
on the phone and Jim Craig on the phone
and Dan Patrick and I have had this
conversation with the day Nets and our
guys here al maybe as Dan calls him the
most interesting man in the world like
he has done everything and just can tell
any stories at any time which is love al
I couldn't agree with you more but also
as we both know from having dinners at a
local eatery that he's got his reserved
Abell at his comedy talk about anything
and that's that's one thing that I
really enjoy about him we do try to stay
away from politics a little bit but
we're not going to go there right not
going to go there but he can just talk
about anything and he's he's also and
I've said this before just I'm having
worked with him for six years at NBC
especially for that generation I don't I
don't want a stereotype he's a single
most supportive person of women that
I've encountered he is so supportive of
women in this business and that is not
always the case
and he is he is a tremendous colleague
and a great friend and has been a
wonderful supporter to me I love the guy
well have you found it from when you
first started say at ESPN back in 89
that or thanks for dropping that date
that makes it all really good no well I
mean I could drop it if your audience
probably wasn't born then you should
know look at Aintree I mean you you have
you have been known as longevity you
hired well which is not easy in this Mel
I am actually very proud of the
longevity you shed I like to say we're
not old we're experienced right exactly
Jane the way things aren't cheap they're
inexpensive hey you know when you when
you talk about something by the way do I
get to tell one Rich Eisen stories you
mean have the floor okay so a a former
colleague of ours at ESPN who has been
actually a consultant and if al Network
Bobby Eaton was speaking to my class at
Boston University last year and I forget
how it came up but I think it was one of
the students was asking about how to
break into the business and he was
giving some thought to me goes there's
only been three people in the history of
his career with ESPN NBC News that could
walk in at an audition and go
immediately who's Sports Center Mike
Tirico Dana Jacobson and Rich Eisen huh
he said you could walk in that moment
and probably be better than most of the
people that were on SportsCenter that
you were as much of a natural as he's
ever been around Wow
thank you for passing that along I
remember my SportsCenter tryout
I stayed o across the the road at the
old Radice
Hotel or the raddest which is not
spelled with a T but with me is Sol okay
it was a touch run down there alligator
yeah yeah we got large they had this lot
there's this huge skyscrapers the only
way to put it it was at that point I
think the tallest building in scenic
Bristol Connecticut was where Otis
Elevator tested their elevators there
was this huge shaft which is with the
building but I remember trying to get to
sleep the night before my tryout and I
couldn't part of the reason was I was so
nervous probably also reason as I heard
the person from the room upstairs going
to the bathroom through the thin floors
thanks for sharing rich I'm just trying
to really made an impression on you
it's called painting a word picture
Andrew uh dramatized um but I also just
remember okay let me just turn on
SportsCenter tonight just to see what's
being talked about so it was the big
show with Dana Keefe and sure enough
back in that day they the tapes that
they used actual tapes with later okay
they used the same ones for my audition
the next day so I already thought to
myself while I was watching dan and
Keith do it you know I would have said
it this way I would have done it this
way I removed and then when it was my
audition I was already ready so Bob may
have thought I kind of game the system
in a way that's kind of like Star Trek
gaming the system but that was nice make
it worked out no matter what everything
did and I want to take a quick 60-second
break and talk about some of the days
that we were back at ESPN together and
then ask you what you think is the most
important NFL storyline coming into the
season I've given you front-load there
you go I'm back in 60 seconds here with
Andrea Kramer here on the Richardson
show
[Music]
welcome back to the retros and chill
Andrea Kramer chilling out with us here
on the program when when you were with
ESPN your was your first assignment in
Chicago is that where you were that you
were in Chicago correspondent with ESP I
opened yesterday in Chicago Bureau in
1989 and was that because Jordan was
making something of something there
Jimmy Roberts in New York right and they
had Chris Myers in Los Angeles and they
wanted they wanted a bureau in Chicago
and obviously as you know chicag was
pretty great sports town so that's why
they started it there but my first ever
live event was the 1989 draft and I was
assigned to be at the home of agent
Steve Zucker whose star client this guy
named Deion Sanders was there that the
stories are showing that picture right
now
yes and and every time the draft comes
up discos on Sports Illustrated's iconic
photos of him
great was I asked him if you can if you
can see what he's wearing I actually
asked him live oh I can see you're
wearing your signing bonus already and
all I heard was berm and Chris Berman in
my ear going did she really say that did
she ask him if he's wearing a signing
bonus I mean look at that look at this
yeah old Italians and then that tracks
you it was a crazy it was a crazy day
and and you know his then-girlfriend was
there as mom was there and it was it was
amazing that was my first live event
produced by Fred Goodell II who's now
Sunday Night Football Fred to Delhi yeah
so he was there with you back in Bristol
oh he was anyways well you was he was
producing the draft is a draft exactly
so that was never get to get your first
so what happened it was Deion Sanders
yeah um so when you were in Chicago and
the Jordan years were were beginning to
amass did you realize what you were in
the middle of welder so here I am
you know this budding journalist right
and the first of
vent that I did was Game five in the
playoffs Bulls Pistons and I was sitting
on the floor of the old Chicago Stadium
ball shall we miss them what a spot and
big old Comiskey and or just like the
garden but it was really the garden you
could fit the old Chicago Stadium by the
way within the confines of the United
Center yoga swing I mean I'm sitting
there and you know again I'm trying to
be I I I'm this serious journalist
lights go down and the whole panoply of
of event starts and I'm sitting on this
is kind of cool because this is you know
you have to allow yourself those moments
I actually probably don't think I've
allowed myself enough of those moments
over the course of my career but that
was the start and then yeah I did all
six of Jordans championships but I did I
did everything I did you know the good
the bad the ugly the game the gambling
in Atlantic City the death of his father
following him on on the road when he
went and played baseball you name it and
one of the things that I'm really super
proud of is that when he came back to
first time the first interview that he
granted was with me and I remember there
was a writer at the same Co Chronicle
who wrote you know Diane Sawyer was
trying dan Rather edition it but he sat
down with Andrea Kramer because he had
inure he trusted her and and he
respected her and that really resonated
for me that was a big deal well that's
been a theme throughout your whole
career what do you make of the LeBron
Jordan argument that's going on right
now that that LeBron should never be in
the same breath as Michael or that he
should be within a similar breath of
Michael what do you think I've always
shaved at the next the next Rich Eisen
the next Michael Jordan the next you
know give people their generational do
in my opinion and I've said this
regarding Jordan regarding athletes even
in other sports that get compared to him
there will never be a Michael Jordan
because in my opinion Sports doesn't
exist the way doesn't look like what it
did when he came in the marketing the
branding it just doesn't exist and I and
I've said it every athlete every athlete
today Tom Brady and
and all of your your uggs in your ditch
every athlete owes a debt of gratitude
to Michael Jordan it's just that simple
Tiger also absolutely yeah because he
was the first to to really bring this
kind of attention to an athlete as a
branding mechanism and then in terms of
his basketball skills I mean go in fix
and don't lose any and because I'm I'm
sorry I'm a ring girl you know I mean I
I love Dan Marino I've got the ultimate
respect for him but in my opinion I'm
just of the belief he'll never be the
greatest because he never won a
championship I mean that's what that's
what the goal is not just to make the
Hall of Fame not just to have the
amazing numbers it's to win a
championship so to me the greatest are
the ones who have won the championship
Andrew Kramer here in the Rich Eisen
show the best athlete you've we've
covered I know I'm just tap-danced a
little bit so you can go through your
mental rolodex here Olympics NFL NBA
I mean period who you've come across
well III I like to say that I've been
privileged and honored to have worked
with and covered what I call the two
greatest Michaels in all the sports
Michael Jordan and Michael Phelps and
very swollen Dixon and covering swimming
in Beijing in 2008 for NBC it's still to
me the greatest individual achievement
that I think we'll ever see I don't
think we'll ever see another athlete in
any sport male or female when eight gold
medals in a single Olympics it was it
was really an amazing thing to to watch
and you'll appreciate this when you're
covering a Super Bowl as I did for NBC
and the game ends and and the confetti
falls and and you've got a couple
minutes before you have to go track down
the MVP or whatever it is when you're
doing the Olympics they get out of the
pool about where that the end of your
desk is and they walk over and you're
right there
so the amount of time that you have to
gather yourself is a little daunting and
when there were races with him with his
seven with Michael seven gold medal in
2008 when he won the
100 flyby 1/100 of a second right that
was one of the greatest experiences that
you could possibly imagine him he was
seventh at the turn he was seventh at
the fifty so those things really
resonated for me that was that was
pretty amazing to witness well you just
saw him at an event do you do you think
he's done you thinking maybe does it one
more time because his his his kid will
have been will be of an age to remember
when Dad swam at an Olympics would he is
that what might bring him back to the
pool what do you think well it's
interesting because of course he sits
here in 2017 saying no no no and boomer
his son will be able to see all the
video and this and that and I said yeah
we'll talk to me in a year because you
trained for Rio two years out so 2018 is
two years out I mean he keeps insisting
that he's that he is done he's super
busy he is all over though all over the
country all over the world being Michael
Phelps it's it's big business he also is
talking a lot about mental mental
illness issues depression that he that
he suffered both ian is close friend
Allison Schmitt is his other roommate
they testified in front of Congress and
this is a really big deal for him as I
think you know but let's just see he
insists he's done but I'm going to take
another year to wait and see
couple more minutes left here with you
Andrew Kramer what do you think is the
most important storyline going into the
2017 NFL season what do you think the
one thing that just strikes me is will
the Patriots do it again I I never even
done before I think that's spot on
and they're loaded aankhen and who can I
have said multiple times with car coming
back and and Marshawn Lynch joining that
offensive line with the offense as it is
and the defense maybe taking another
step forward with Ken Norton jr. behind
the controls and now Rod Woodson is the
coach of the defensive backs that they
are the only team that has a shot at
putting Tom Brady on a plane next
January for the right to play in
Minnesota
then they play you know in Mexico on a
huge game right on a Monday night coming
up this season and how Jack Del Rio do
as a coach in Jacksonville against Brady
hmm well I mean it's a different I know
it is a different it is a similar scheme
defensively but yeah to me too that that
sort of history is I love history and to
watch see if they can do that and if and
if Brady can can you get the ethics and
they've loaded up offensively I mean he
arguably on paper it's June we know how
that works right there offensive weapons
no there's no Randy Moss but you know
Brandon cooks already just the route
running the deep speed and it's not as
though Brady can't get that ball down
the field I mean it's what was the what
was the movie with Brad Pitt where they
reversed aged Oh Benjamin but Benjamin
but didn't excuse the Benjamin Button of
quarter but yeah isn't it kind of
looking that way a little bit
well I mean and we already talked about
it here we're congratulations to Rex
Burkhead and Mike Gillis Lee they're
going to the Pro Bowl because they have
the Corey Dillon trash into treasure
award nominees of this year for the new
matrix well I think you scored 104
points and three playoff game pleasure
and no Grunk they're not going to play
in the Pro Bowl officially because
they'll be in Minnesota for business
thank you from now it's in Orlando is
yes I tried that no I said there will be
a loss of value on you're saying that be
in the program I ain't getting ready
that's your say it's tough to disagree
with that Andrea thank you for coming on
this will hopefully be the first of many
well thank you because you really have
kept on me and I really appreciate it
I'm just and I'm really really happy to
be here in person it was always a
pleasure to see you give Susie my best I
will I appreciate that thank you I give
give the Commissioner my desk is said
well when your Temasek andrew creamier
and the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches